Ca y est, c’est l’été !
Que vous preniez des vacances ou pas... Vous allez avoir des activités que vous n’avez pas le reste de l’année.
Et du coup… Vous allez être confrontez a des problèmes auxquels vous ne vous attendez pas.
*:Fond de musique rock:* Tout l’été DTC vous aide a éviter..
les pièges et les dangers qui menace votre bien être ...
...et votre santé
DTC … Partenaire de votre été !
Une petite viande, du ( ? ), un poisson, des légumes…
Le barbecue c’est comme on aime
Mais attention, pour profiter de ce p’tit bonheur culinaire et du reste de son été...
Et du reste de sa vie même…
Y’a deux trois p’tit trucs a savoir
...
*°:- ☠ Generique ☠ -:°*
♪ Taaatalaa tatatata taaaalalatataaa
tatatata taaaalalatataaa
talaata taalalatataaa
pam paalampa tatataaaaalaa tatata
Paaampalapam paaaaammm... ♪
D’abords, le barbecue… Ca brûle.
(Romain: ) - Noooon ?
Ok..Tu grandiras jamais enfaite …
-Si
-Beeen... Non
- Non...
-Si
- Non !
- Si !
NON !
On parle quand même de 200 cents accidents chaque année en France,
qui peuvent toucher un peu tout le monde
C’est-à-dire : Celui qui s’occupe du barbecue,
les gens qui sont autour et surtout les enfants
Donc on va voir ce qu’il faut faire en cas d’accident,
Mais comme prèvenir c’est toujours mieux que guerrir :
quelques petites régles a respecter,
pour se régaler sans se brûler
:)
;)
Avant même de commencer, s’il y a des enfants autours,
éloignez les et tenez les a distance jusqu’à ce que le barbecue soit éteins.
Assurez-vous que le barbecue est bien aux normes de sécurité
et choisissez bien l’endroit où vous allez l’installer.
Il faut que le terrain soit bien plat pour que l’appareil soit stable,
à l’ abri du vent
et bien dégagé pour pas mettre le feu autour de soi.
Ne vous mettez pas sous un arbre ni a coter d’une haie
ni a coter d’une maison
ou trop proche de matériel qui risqueras de s’enflammer.
C’est d’autant plus important d’bien choisir son emplacement
qu’une fois que le barbecue serat allumer,
faudra surtout pas essayer de le déplacer.
Choisissez bien votre tenue aussi…
Pas de vêtements amples
Pas de manche longue…
Et plutôt du coton,
/!\ Surtout pas du synthétique /!\ Parce que quand ça brûle,
ça fond
et ça colle à la peau.
Prévoyez des gants de cuisine aussi...
Une fois allumé, ne ravivez jamais le feu avec liquide inflammable
comme de l'essence ou de l'alcool a brûler
et gardez toujours a porté de main de quoi éteindre les flammes si besoin
Comme un sceau ou un jet d'eau
Pour le surveiller et surveiller les gens qui sont autour,
Ne vous éloigner jamais trop du feu
Pas trop prés quant même...
Et allez-y doucement sur l'apero...
♪ Faaiiiiree a mangerrrrrr....
Boireee de l'alcooooolll ... ♪
Ajougdr'hui...
Lle Bbahrrbecue....
KABOOOOOMM
Une fois que vous avez terminez,
éteigniez bien votre barbecue
et restez vigilant tant qu’il n’as pas complètement refroidit
Bon mais si malgré toutes ces précautions un drame arrive quand même,
Qu’est-ce qu’il faut faire ?
Premier cas de figure :
Quelqu’un est en flamme et ses vêtements brûlent
Bon là on est mal…
Mais faut pas cédé à la panique
Premiere chose a faire :
Demandez à quelqu’un d’appeler le Samu au 15,
Éloigner la personne du barbecue
et empêchez la de courir…
Ca attiseras les flammes
et il ira foutre le feu partout
Ensuite dites-lui de se mettre au sol et trouvez une couverture,
Attention, pas en synthétique hien…
Pour les raisons qu’on a vue toute à l’heure
N’importe quel grand morceau de tissu fera l’affaire
C’est pour le recouvrir et étouffer les flammes
Si vous avez pas ça sous la main,
vous pouvez aussi lui demandez de rouler par terre pour éteindre le feu
Une fois que c’est fait,
Faites doucement couler de l’eau a une 20ene de degrés
20 cm au-dessus des brûlures
Pendant 20 minutes
C’est pour refroidir et calmer les douleurs
Retirez le reste des vêtements,
sauf s’il colle à la peau et aussi les bijoux
Les zones brûlé vont gonfler,
il faut éviter que les bagues, les bracelets ou les chaînes reste coincés dedans
En attendant l’arrivée d’secours,
il faut laisser la victime sur le sol en position demi-assise,
c’est-à-dire légèrement penché vers l’arrière
et adosser sur quelque chose, sauf s’il le dos a était brûlé
Couvrez-la avec des linges en coton propres et secs pour éviter une hypothermie
C’est-à-dire une chute importante de la température corporel,
à cause des brûlures et du refroidissement
En attendant les secours vous pouvez aussi commander des pizzas,
parce qu’on va pas se mentir…
le barbecue c’est mort
Par contre, ne donner rien a manger ni même a boire a la victime…
Et aller sirotez un peu plus loin, soyez charitable…
Passons au deuxième cas maintenant
Moins dramatique, mais grave quand même
Les vêtements n’sont pas en feu, mais quelqu’un s’est brûlé
Ben une grande partie des conseils qu’on vient de voir reste valable
On éloigne la victime de barbecue,
on fait couler de l’eau a 20°,  pendant 20mn a 20 cm au-dessus des brûlures
On enlève les bijoux et les vêtements sauf s’ils collent à la peau
On enveloppe la brûlure dans un linge propre en coton
et attention,
s’il y as des cloques, on ne perce pas
et on ne met rien dessus sans l’avis d’un médecin
Si la brûlure et grave, il faut appeler le 15
Alors… vous allez me dire  « Mais comment on sais que c’est grave »
(Romain) – Mais comment on sais que c’est grave ?
- P’tinn ça y est, ça recommence…?
D’abords chez un enfant de moins de 5 ans,
une personne de plus de 60 ans
ou quelqu’un qui a une maladie chronique, comme du diabète, une insuffisance cardiaque
ou une maladie qui affaiblie son système immunitaire
Une brûlure, c’est toujours grave
Pour le reste tout dépend de trois choses
L’etendue de la brûlure
Ca profondeur
Et sa localisation
Toutes les brûlures au niveau du visage, du cou, des mains ou des organes génitaux
sont considéré comme grave
Toutes brûlures de plus de 10% de la surface corporel total
c’est grave aussi
Pour calculer ça,
la paume de la main de la victime,
c’est à peu près 1% de sa surface corporel
Et enfin on classe la profondeur des brûlures en degrés
Le 1er degrés, ça correspond a peu prés a un coup de soleil classique
Au 2eme degrés superficiel, des cloques apparaissent sur une peau rouge voir fendiller
Et la gravité apparaît a partir du deuxième degrés profond
avec destruction de l’épiderme, des cloques, des partie blanchâtre et des zone insensible
Au 3eme degres la peau est comme du carton,
sèche, anesthésié, parfois noire
A ce stade, la destruction de épiderme est total
et la chirurgie est obligatoire
Dans tous les cas, si vous avez un doute
Appelez le 15, ils vous diront quoi faire
Bon allez, vous en faites pas
Si vous respectez les régles de sécurité
Y’a aucunes raison que ce genre de trucs puissent arrivé un jour
Avant de se quitter, un dernier truc
Y’a pas qu’en brulant que le barbecue peux vous faire du mal
Quand la graisse du poisson ou de la viande coule sur les braises
Ca provoque des flammes ou de la fumée
qui au contact des aliments forme des substance cancérigènes
Les hydrocarbures aromatiques polycycliques
Et la cuisson a trop haute température
Au barbecue ou pas d’ailleurs
Ca favorise la formation d’acides aminés hétérocycliques
Eux aussi cancérigènes
Donc retenez ce conseil :
Quand c’est cramé, faut pas manger
Là encore, quelques p’tits conseils pour pouvoir profitez de votre barbecue sans risques
Nettoyez la grille avant la cuisson
Allumez votre feu à l’ancienne, ou si vous utilisez un accélérateur, prenez en un qui fait pour ça
et attendez qu’il ai complètement brûler pour mettre vos aliments a grillé
Utilisez du charbon épuré pour éviter les emanations toxiques
Évitez les viandes et les poissons trop gras et retirez les bouts de graisse avant la cuisson
Vous pouvez faire mariné tout ça dans la bière..
Oui dans la bière…
Parce que ça a un effet protecteur
Vous mangez des fruits et des légumes aussi, pour les même raisons
Placez les aliments 10 cm minimum au-dessus des braises,
ca correspond a peu prés a une temperature de 220°
Il vaut mieux que ça cuise doucement avec la chaleur
Mais surtout pas au contact des flammes
Si c’est cramé faut pas manger donc…
Retirez les morceaux noircis
Si vous faites de la viande, cuisez la bien
pour évitez les intoxications alimentaires
Et puis, même si c'est tentant
Faites pas de barbecue tous les jours ...
Deux fois par semaines, c'est bien
Voilà ! DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
On se retrouve non pas la semaine prochaine
mais dans 15 jours pour une nouvelle video spécial été
En attendant
Bonne vacances a ceux qu'en ont
Bon courage pour ceux qu'en ont pas
Et pour tout le monde
Mettez vous bien et portez vous bien
:)